hey guys i'm ryan right today i'm going
to be reviewing the movie the San
Andreas Fault in Our Stars this is going
to be one of my more straight to the
point reviews yes the acting is quite
cheesy at times the dialogue is pretty
cliche the way the events play out can
be rather convenient for our main
characters anytime a sudden problem
occurs the characters have an immediate
solution to it I'm gonna rush past all
that because we don't go to watch
disaster movies for those reasons I mean
yes the disaster movies would be better
if they had some real good script [ __ ]
going on but they usually don't and I
usually hate these kind of films but I
know people go to disaster films to
watch disaster and honestly that's where
this film has some strong moments I mean
I've grown quite immune to disaster
flick sight most of the time I'm usually
really bored but also during every
action sequence I thought it really
intense at times I was terrified it's in
big respect to what the director did and
how we count for the movie like the
director puts you in the middle of these
disaster sequences with the characters
like you see it all pretty much from
their perspective like they'll be
running you're following them and
suddenly to the left a concrete drops
and kill someone the wind takes someone
away water washes someone away like
there's a disaster that occurs next to
them and it makes you feel like at any
moment someone's gonna die so rather
than a bunch of sweeping huge epic
landscape shots I mean sure there's a
few in there actually puts you in the
situation with these characters during
the disaster as much the time you walk
away from these movies going the special
effects were great but the movie sucked
the special effects in this film are
great but because of the intensity it
does add a new level to disaster flicks
in a way like even in the opening before
the San Andreas Fault starts going crazy
there's a helicopter rescue sequence
that's really intense and that's like
look not even the disaster has started
during it so if you watch the trailers
for this movie there's two things you're
gonna want your
want some awesome disaster sequences and
you're going to want the rock to do a
passable job like even though the
writing isn't the greatest the
performances are good for the most part
mean like the rock is good he makes her
a likable hero kicking her in
earthquakes ass I mean no matter how
many rocks are thrown at Dwayne Johnson
no one can take it down the one true
rock but his relationship with carla
Gugino i enjoyed she's pretty hot for an
older lady she plays his ex-wife he
likes rock hard dick apparently
alexandra daddario is your typical
ridiculously hot daughter who got some
smarts from what daddy taught her I'd
like her to call me daddy in bed you
know what I mean I wanted to call me Dad
for a shot she's into bikini the one
performance I actually elevated this
film a little bit in even though this
character is equipped with some pretty
cliche lines Paul Giamatti my Paul
Giamatti sounds like the Joker Paul
Giamatti usually these types of films
are just a combination of a bunch of
different disasters happening and it can
be a little hard to follow why this [ __ ]
is actually happening but in this film
it's a simple enough promise and it's
easier to understand through apology
embodies character like you get the
information pretty much easy to
understand from his character but he
also provides a strong level of fear
towards the situation which makes it
scary because you're watching the guy
who knows everything and he's terrified
of what he knows so yeah this is film
full of cliche and cheesy pneus and its
script yes one hundred percent yes but
the film is mainly destruction due to
the San Andreas Fault and because it's
mainly that it's mainly intense and it's
mainly entertaining and it adds
something fresh to what could have been
a roland emmerich type of film and I guy
who sucks at directing let me get
straight to the point here oh and all i
gotta say san andreas got it
disastrously right
alright guys thanks for tuning in for my
review of san andreas you can follow us
on Facebook Instagram and Twitter you
can also catch my videos on Latino
Review com and last but not least if you
want to get updated every time one of my
reviews or videos is out to do any click
on this one of my my dig dis subscribe
that's right the Didache let me tell you
something about this little rock every
time he pounds his lady the earth quakes
and it's all his fault you try coming up
with a dick joke every episode [ __ ]